hi I'm Erik Bosse and of interest in
games recent digital release featured a
ton of bonus footage related to end game
and infinity war including something I
never thought would actually see the
light of day the rumoured fake death
scenes that screenwriters wrote to try
to keep secret the film's major twists
Marvel head Kevin Feige and in-game
executive producer Trina Tran revealed
that during production for infinity war
and endgame they used a system of
multiple versions of the scripts a
CodeRed script which was the real cannon
version that would be in the final cut
and an alternate code blue script a
misdirect fake version that they
distributed to maintain confusion and
keep the secrets a red herring or a blue
harry and phi game tran revealed four
scenes showing alternate versions of the
deaths of loki Kimora envisioned an
infinite wort and Thanos an end game
which they animated and produced to give
us a sense of what these opponents would
have looked like
now these deaths were the most critical
because these along with Tony Stark a
Natasha Romanov an in-game we're actual
legit deaths that the actors had to know
about not the dusting that they could
just accomplish mostly with V effects
and then bring all those characters back
anyway you know now that I think of it
Loki Gamora vision and Thanos all came
back or are coming back in other forms
so nothing is permanent and comics let's
break down each of these for dummy
scenes to see what they tell us about
the alternate ideas Marvel might have
for these characters in the future and
spoiler warning for everything an MCU up
to now I don't hear any complaint or
saying I needed more than a month to see
far from home okay the first scene shows
us Loki's death in the opening minutes
of Infinity Ward now this is a moment
Loki tried to trick Thanos with a hidden
dagger but instead if Thanos stopping
the strike with the space stone in this
alternate script all of Loki was a fake
projection good luck brother
the Sun will shine again shall we pursue
him no need we have all we need so one
interesting element about this alternate
scene well other than a hilarious
animation and goofy sound effects is
that Loki being a projection and faking
his death was actually a huge conspiracy
theory that went around between infinity
war and endgame this time last year we
were pretty obsessed with this idea now
obviously it's not the case
Loki did indeed die on the ass
guardianship and Danis was right new
resurrections this time but Loki was
also kind of right the Sun will rise on
them once more just an alternate reality
Sun the version of Loki from 2012 who
stole the space stone during the time
Heights to branch off into a new
separate reality a vilnus [ __ ] II
Loki just how we like him on to the next
alternate death scene this one takes
place after Thanos sacrificed Gamora on
Vermeer but rather than waking up alone
in a pool with the soul stone in his
hand
this code blue script showed this
panelist of Titan hmm the soul of the
universe is yours to hold
[Music]
don't do this
so this one's super bonkers it appears
as though Gamora is still alive
afterwards it's not really clear how she
appears to be suspended as a marionette
by Thanos maybe he's using the reality
stone I was also thinking maybe this
could be the presentation with the
cosmic power this whole stone or Red
Skull it leads to wonder did Dano
sacrifice Kimura at all really I think
what was going on here is that Thanos
sacrificed himself and that's how we
ended up in the pool meanwhile Gamora
was being puppeted and controlled by
Thanos using the reality stone and this
would happened some time after capturing
her from the collectors vault and by
puppeting her is how he found the soul
stone on Vermeer and only now does he
release her from those bonds since he's
gotten what he's wanted now this is how
it went down it's a pretty big deal that
Thanos was willing to kill himself and
that kind of makes him less of a
sympathetic figure because think about
it it would mean that he loves himself
more than he loves Gamora as a daughter
figure it's also worth noting that in
this animated version Thanos already has
the green time stone and the theatrical
version Thanos doesn't acquire the time
stone until after Vermeer in the soul
stone so it looks as though in this code
blue script Thanos was getting the soul
stone and releasing Gamora as a last
stop before earth in the final step and
moving on to that final step vision in
the mind stone in Wakanda after that
nose pops the deepest zit ever her verse
Pleasantville envision the alternate
version the scene gave vision an
interesting final moment with Wanda
Maximoff Wanda Maximoff how may I be of
assistance today so this is interesting
the implication here is that wind vision
lost the mine stone he doesn't die he
just kind of reboots with his memory and
personality wiped essentially he reverts
back to Jarvis and this is actually
something we've been wondering about now
that vision will return in the upcoming
Disney Plus streaming series one
division set after the events of endgame
could vision be restored in Jarvis form
without his memories kind of like wall-e
before Eva kissed his soul back into him
which totally shouldn't have worked but
you know Disney how much a visions soul
was contained inside the mine stone and
now that the stones remain reduced to
atoms in this main timeline what does
that mean for
vision soul if you ever had one I mean
how much soul does a guy have if you
can't taste paprika could Wanda Maximoff
reassemble his soul or is an Android
body with an AI voice that sounds like a
former man enough to keep her happy I
feel like it would for a lot of women
and moving on to the final alternate
death scene from the opening minutes of
endgame in which the Avengers tracked
down Thanos to his farm in the garden
and Thor goes from ahead yeah so maybe
this is just a joke maybe all of these
scenes are jokes but I leave no Infinity
stone unturned but presumably the
Avengers would have left this older
weekend Thanos alone in peace since
really there's no point in bothering him
other than to just unleash their anger
but maybe there was an alternate version
of the endgame ending in which this
older Thanos joins the Avengers to face
the younger 2014 Thanos that Thanos who
wanted to use the stones to tear the
entire universe down to shreds as well
and start over which kind of would have
been contrary to older 2018 Thanos his
aims may be 2014 thanasis would have
sought out his older 2018 self and
decapitated him the way Thor did to him
in the theatrical cut or the way 2014
Thanos did to an alternate cap in the
rejected concept that the screenwriters
discussed which of these fake deaths do
you wish could have been canon in the
final version of Avengers infinity war
an endgame comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on instagram twitter
ID a vas subscribed into rock stars or
breakdown some theories about everything
Marvel Cinematic Universe related thank
you for joining me
and if Marvel could get this amazing
animator to bring to light the ultimate
to cap cap and living tribunal dark
trial scenes we would be very grateful
[Music]